[Music]
hello there you are watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive in the next
half hour we'll see what's making the
headlines with the journalist and author
rachel sharby and the editor of the
jewish chronicle jake wallace simons so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages and a quick spoiler uh warning for
strictly fans who have not yet seen the
result you might want to look away for
the next minute or so you have been
warned uh the sunday telegraph that
leads with the resignation of the brexit
minister lord frost over disagreements
concerning relations with the eu and
northern ireland
the sunday times describes lord lord
frost's departure as indicating a
deepening crisis for boris johnson
describing the country as held hostage
by the virus the sunday express looks at
the conflict between the increasing
danger of the omicron variant and the
desire of tory backbenchers to avoid new
restrictions
well the sunday mirror understands the
prime minister has been briefed by
government scientists that there could
be as many as 3 000 people a day going
into hospital with the virus in january
according to the sunday people by
christmas day 50 000 nhs staff could be
absent from work because of omicron
scotland's sunday mail puts that figure
at 5 000 in that part of the uk alone
and on a lighter note here's why we gave
that spoiler warning the star
congratulates this year's winner of
strictly come dancing
and we're joined tonight by rachel
sharby and jake wallace simons welcome
to you both lovely to have you both on
this evening
let's start with the timing of lord uh
frost's resignation i mean obviously uh
the timing today but but also uh the
timing not quite uh
soon enough to get into some of the
front pages for tomorrow morning uh i
notice uh certainly the sunday mail the
daily star the scotland scotland on
sunday as well i haven't managed to get
it onto their front pages if they were
going to
uh many of them holding back i think in
order to try and get this news on the
front page
uh
lord frost says he handed in his
resignation a week ago before
the north shropshire by-election defeat
of the conservatives
i wonder whether you think he was trying
to stick the knife into boris johnson
whether the timing of this suggests it's
another
knife in boris johnson after well two or
three weeks now of uh of issues and
scandals for him and his leadership uh
rachel what do you make of that
well whether or not he intended to stick
the knife in the knife has definitely
been stuck in to boris johnson and his
leadership uh the sunday times is
describing this as a crisis the
deepening crisis now engulfing the prime
minister as you say coming days after
that just body
in the shropshire by-election where you
know they lost their historic and safe
seats in a in a catastrophic way so
you know it does seem that support is
just disappearing from boris johnson and
his leadership and this resignation is
going to be a really really serious blow
i mean david frost is a key
ally
um and the key um player in in brexit of
course
um
i'm not so sure that it is just
disagreement over
uh the direction of travel over the
government i suspect you know
david frost
one of the architects of brexit has
realized that you know it is a bit of a
square peg in the round hole whenever
especially when it comes to um the no
negotiations over the northern ireland
protocol and to leave in the middle of
those negotiations is also pretty
damning just in and of itself
very interesting uh certainly the the
times uh leading uh with this tomorrow
frost uh resigns and the telegraph
frost the prospect of a winter lockdown
as well frost quits cabinet as johnson
considers christmas uh lock down the
implication there that uh frost is
quitting over this issue over these
coveted issues rather than anything else
but i wonder jake wallace simons whether
it could also have been about brexit we
certainly know uh that it was leaked uh
i think as long as a week ago that um
senior officials were briefing that
perhaps the uk was going to start
backing down on its demands for
oversight of the northern ireland
protocol to be removed from the european
court uh of justice now that would uh
have frustrated
david frost certainly do you think it is
all about uh covert measures and
national insurance rises or do you think
there is part of it that is about the
direction brexit was taking
i think it's a whole range of things to
be honest i mean you you mentioned a few
of them there uh there's his
reservations about um the uh possibility
of kovid restrictions coming back
there's his worries about tax hikes and
national insurance rises uh and of
course anxiety is about brexit as well
and also the uh the sunday time has
mentioned his anxieties about the uh
priority given to climate change and
government policy i think if we take all
of these things together what we can see
is uh lord frost being expression of a
disgruntlement with boris by the right
wing of his party the right-wing
backbenchers and that's a serious
problem
for the prime minister because uh
generally speaking historically the
right wing of the party has been behind
boris they've been his supporters
the left wing of the party had been uh
in opposition to him uh but boris has
done this strange thing that over the as
time has gone by since he's been prime
minister he's changed his ideology that
we all knew from when he was a
journalist from being
on the libertarian side of things to the
authoritarian side you know he's come
out in favor of vaccine passports he's
become you know a tax and spend
a sort of lefty really i mean you've got
a tax burden now that's the highest it's
been since the 50s
and he's veering towards lockdown um as
opposed to um you know standing in favor
of freedom also doesn't really
correspond with the uh boris that people
thought they knew and so he sort of
alienated his base if you like he's
donated the right to the party and the
left of the party didn't like him anyway
and so he's looking very very isolated
tonight very interesting i mean what
you're saying there really picked up on
the sunday telegraph which on its uh
front page chaos as at number 10 as
brexit negotiator leaves post uh
exactly as you were saying his
interventions frost's interventions have
echoed the views of many tory back
benches and his resignation is likely to
add fears about the direction uh of uh
the government rachel shelby we keep
asking the question what is the tipping
point for boris johnson as leader
is this it
i mean in all truth the tipping point
for boris johnson came long before he
was prime minister and long before he
was leader of the conservative party all
of his failings were known and have been
known for a long time the tipping point
comes when the conservatives no longer
believe that he is like their golden
goose that lays these electoral
victories it's got nothing to do with
anything else not his corruption charges
not his compulsive lying not his
incompetence and the bungling of the
pandemic which has left you know such an
extraordinary number of people uh
tragically killed and has left our
economy recovering slower than any other
none of those things matter what matters
to conservatives is whether boris
johnson can win them the next election
and the minute the the perception is
that he can't is the minute that uh you
know they will make moves to replace
them
well let's uh let's move on to some of
uh well what would have been i think the
front pages of all the papers had it not
been for this uh resignation tonight uh
nightmare before christmas according to
the sunday uh mail there is of course
considering christmas lockdowns on the
front of the sunday telegraph uh the
independent tough measures needed before
new year the prime minister is told uh
and the sunday express held hostage by
the virus so omicron
just these few days now what a week
before christmas exactly a week before
christmas the question now for the
government over this weekend as they
discuss this and what to do uh with the
limited data they have is whether to go
in hard on restrictions just in case and
then be able to ease back off those uh
or whether to delay wait for some
data to come in
with the huge risk of course that
they're too late for an overcrowded nhs
jake wallace simon i mean it is an
impossible decision i'm not going to ask
you uh uh to me to make it certainly uh
but as you consider what we know about
boris johnson what do you think is going
to happen what do you think is going to
emerge over the next few days are we
likely to have further restrictions
before christmas
well i don't have a crystal ball any
more than the next man but it does seem
that the winds are blowing in the
direction of the restrictions um even
before christmas which is something that
we had really hoped uh was not going to
happen
um and i think that you know things feel
different this time very much so and
we've all been vaccinated once twice
three times uh more than 20 million
people in britain
have had the third jab and that's been
accelerated greatly at the moment
and if we look at the latest figures
from yougov we're seeing that whereas in
previous lockdowns that there was
overwhelming public support for those
measures now more than 60 percent of
people oppose them i think there's been
a real sea change in the public's
attitude towards lockdown uh given the
fact that we are beginning to see data
uh about omricon that indicates that
it's mild that uh that the death rate uh
has not bounced up uh significantly in
uh south africa um and uh and people
feel that if we that we know that you
know three jabs does give you protection
that's being accelerated we've had you
know news stories about uh anti-viral
pills which are able to uh greatly
reduce the symptoms of kovid and people
just feel what's the point you know why
are the gov why is the government
seeking to bring in more and more
restrictions when we were told all the
time
that vaccines were the path out of this
mess and it sort of raises the specter
of a population that is the most
vaccinated population on earth probably
at this time
living with the constant threat of
lockdowns
to cope with
variations in the virus which we all
know are going to happen i mean the
government really has had a long time to
get it stocks in a row in terms of
preparing for the variations that are
inevitably going to occur uh and
measures such as rolling out the the
pill that will satisfy it that will sort
of uh cure or not cure reduce the
symptoms of kobe and the jabs and
perhaps uh bringing back knighting their
igniting your hospitals to increase
capacity those sorts of things really
should have been done by now i think the
public is getting really sick and tired
of lockdowns yeah of course although the
mirror you know warning that 3 000
people a day could be in hospital uh
by uh january the times uh funnily
enough slightly more on your point
they're saying cover patients could be
treated uh at home so huge amounts of
data
still limited for the government to wade
through as it approaches this weekend
and its discussions on future
restrictions or not before christmas so
we'll be back coming up as much of the
nation ponders changing its christmas
plans could the queen follow suit we'll
be discussing that next
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview uh with me now rachel sharpie
and jake wallace simons and let's go
straight back into uh our papers this
evening uh with the fact that it's not
just all of us who are now
looking at our christmas plans and
thinking what's going to be feasible
what's not the queen is also looking at
her festive blands that's according to
the sunday telegraph rachel tell us a
bit more about that
well yes that's right the queen is
looking at the government guidelines um
with caution just before we go into that
i just want to correct something that we
went into the break with because i do
think it's important i'm not a scientist
but i have been following what
scientists have been saying about
omicron and i just want to say that so
far there's absolutely no evidence to
suggest that omicron is a milder milder
variant of kobit that's just not known
we can't copy-paste the experience in
southern africa onto the uk and the
other thing is that um
you know the reason to go into a circuit
breaker would be
to allow more people to get the booster
jab and to prevent the nhs from getting
overwhelmed not least because so many
nhs staff are getting sick
um it's not the case that the uk has one
of the most vaccinated populations in
the world either plenty of people in the
uk are not vaccinated including in
london which is one of the reasons why
london has such a high uh vaccination uh
infection rate so i just wanted to come
back on those two points but as you say
the queen is looking at her um christmas
plans uh like everyone else she is
having to reappraise uh particularly
looking at the numbers of people who are
due to be invited to celebrate on the
day itself and her aides are suggesting
that uh those plans are now being
revived
absolutely we're all used to seeing
those images of her going to uh the
sandringham church visit that might not
be able uh to happen i guess that just
shows all of us doesn't it jake willis
simons that we are going to have to
think really sensibly about christmas
just very quickly
that's right i think that everybody is
is um is prepared to do that uh i think
that the general mood in the country is
that we know quite a lot with rachel's
right to point out that uh we don't know
everything about this new variant
although i can test some of the
assumptions that she's just made but
that aside um i think that everyone
knows that you know if you've got three
jabs you're better protected than if
you've got two and obviously if you're
unvaccinated you've got very little
protection
people know the questions i'm gonna have
to i'm gonna have to move us on jake i'm
sorry because we don't have long to
discuss uh this a bit of light relief
here why can't a spaniard play a cuban
asks aaron salkin the creator of west
wing this one in the sunday times talk
us through it
well it's it's just one of these debates
that keeps rumbling on and uh aaron
sorkin the creator of the west wing uh
has come under criticism because he cast
a spanish actor
in the role of a cuban uh in his latest
film um and he said that uh you know
demands that you have to only have
actors playing the same racial
background uh as they actually have
uh is re-segregation and i think there's
a lot to be said for that argument i
mean i think there comes a point where
anti-racism sort of goes full circle and
becomes sort of racism again uh where
you're trying to you know you're so
concerned to think of race first that
you begin to put the sorts of demands on
people that the racists did and so i
think that's what he's